but do you think James that this
economic crisis will overcome the cult
mentality that exists among so many of
these people on the left I mean people
don't just shake out occults man I mean
that's Leon festinger right he
infiltrates the UFO call the UFO doesn't
come what a big surprise or no UFO and
then what do people do they say well it
came spiritually and like turned around
because I mean this is so the people who
are are fully brainwashed by this that
they are they need help and I mean it's
really not going to be good for them
what will happen though is that most of
the people that are supporting it most
of the people that are putting their
black Square on their profile or
whatever
aren't that committed they're not
actually fully bought into the cult
they're confused and when things start
to shake they're going to start to see
that this isn't what they thought it was
and a lot of them will start to come
back to reality when you break the
active measure when you break the psyop
when you turn off the television
people's brains start to readjust to the
reality in front of them and this starts
to happen when reality shocks them back
most of them and enough for the key word
I said earlier is a critical mass of
people that's where you're going to get
this this Uprising Steve's talking about
this is when you have a critical mass of
people who say nope no more then it's
going to be everything's gonna start to
change and it's going to change very
quickly we have to keep pressing to get
to that point we have to keep making it
more clear to see through the smoke
grenade that the flashbang you have to
keep doing this but wokeness is an
increasing liability for them and
because of people like you it's going to
keep being an increasing liability for
them and they're not going to be able
they're going to try to get rid of it as
hard as they can when it gets to that
point but James it's it's not the TV
anymore it's big Tech social
I'm trying to make a bigger statement
here because just a few days ago we
finally got the receipts that it was the
intelligence agencies that were pretty
much controlling big Tech social media
oh yeah I don't think this is something
new I think this was happening for a
very long time and when you're able to
shape social media you're able to shape
the minds of the people oh yeah and this
is why since uh the onset of Barack
Obama I was like this is the beginning
of a larger divide and conquer agenda we
saw the destruction of Occupy Wall
Street we've seen the rhetoric change on
of course the the mainstream media but
on social media it was left versus right
black versus white old versus old old
versus young male versus female we we
saw this weaponized in Echo Chambers we
saw this weaponized with algorithms and
I do believe that intelligence agencies
had a play on this engineering this
larger conflict where we are right now
talking about pronouns and genders
rather than holy crap there's not going
to be enough money to pay for heat or
food soon so that's an issue that I
think really needs to be honed into the
Open Secret in Silicon Valley is the
social media companies are almost in
possible to make profitable because of
the server costs and the staff costs so
the question that needs to be answered
is did the intelligence agencies enter
during the Venture round of Facebook I I
think so electricity would q and tell
especially with a lot of the other
organizations that invested a lot of the
money there especially when it came to
alphabet and Google getting all those
contracts getting all those lucrative
deals getting all those tax incentives
get all get all that money back they
unfairly were able to go to the top
because they were connected with all the
intelligence agencies that brought them
there it wasn't an accident I this is a
question I had about Twitter that I was
was mentioning early on with Elon Musk
did he see government involvement and
then say Oh No but the bigger question
then when we start realizing with the
Twitter leaks the Twitter files that the
FBI actually paid to Twitter now granted
it was like 3.8 million or something
what is that like no no no no no but you
got to count the vaccine advertisements
you got to count Go Army ads you got to
count all the federal government Capital
rights because they'll bundle those
together that's hundreds of millions of
dollars but so so here's here's the
point I wanted to make the other day it
was Elon who responded to Ian miles
Chong who said in order for Twitter to
be profitable it has to become a
platform for creators of video and
writing and Elon said something like
true
and I say no that's not true I'm sorry I
mean it's somewhat true you do need to
have a good platform that people can use
you can monetize but uh right now we're
not only in this convention center we're
on YouTube YouTube subsidized YouTube
the the cost of live streaming this show
we could never make enough money off the
show to actually pay for it
so it's a weird start it's a weird
situation where the big Tech social
media companies are subsidized and I've
always wondered where does that money
come from there is a theory of remember
when Facebook went public and they had
this meteoric crash I mean were they
trying to make certain investors
disappear in a public market of an
exchange and it didn't exactly go right
interesting so you you think I'm not
thinking I'm just asking a question it
was the most fumbled IPO in modern
history and you gotta Wonder that's also
the company that is probably in bed with
every intelligence agency and it was an
IPO that didn't just miss by ten dollars
you remember it was supposed to debut at
like 50 a share right and crater to 18
we're like what happened I wonder why
they have the best banks doing their IPO
right remember
the creation of these companies come out
of the top engineering schools in the
country right the the top Engineers the
top computer scientists you know at
Stanford at MIT and yeah
all of those universities are
essentially adjuncts to the National
Security State okay they're all
underwritten the university today are
virtually underwritten by the US
government and federal funds almost all
of that is tied back to some sort of
National Security State so the engineers
themselves the engineering has all been
underwritten when these things first
start the Venture Capital companies that
put in the hedge fund companies most of
these have strong relationships to the
federal government in the National
Security State okay this is all a p one
piece of a whole cloth okay and then you
talk about the contracts and how the
revenue goes and all that it all comes
through either the biomedical Security
State or the National Security medical
state which we or state which we've kind
of seen the convergence of during the
CCP covid-19 virus right so this these
are all adjuncts and by the way Facebook
is going to be
10 times or 20 times worse than Twitter
okay because the platform is bigger
you're going to see more and more
involvement you're going to see more and
more involvement in this they actually
say that the people there in in in
Dorsey that this was a
government-controlled operation Twitter
is a crime scene and it is an
intelligence op okay from day one from
the core of its being at the very
engineering schools where it started and
it's that's what I'm saying the
administrative state to to break this to
take this out root and branch is a 10 20
or 30 year project where you're on it
every day okay because it's taken them
since essentially World War II right to
build the National Security State and
this is not going to be easy but it's
everywhere right and it's particularly
in our universities that's why the
universities the the rail heads of
wokeness right now right the great
universities of the University of Texas
of you can look at Arizona State right
right here right these are the rail
heads of wokeness why because they're
living off government money they're
adjuncts they're just they're just
outposts they're the new weapons Labs of
Sandia and Lawrence Livermore right the
old nuclear power weapons Labs the new
weapons labs are social media weapons
created by these universities in
conjunction with the National Security
in the biomedical Security State so we
saw that video from Project Veritas a
while back this uh this employee saying
I worked what four hours a week he's
getting paid six figures we see Elon
Musk come in and he's like these people
are doing nothing and they're getting
paid all this money and I think about
that and I think about uh this this old
thing that it read where the reason why
there's so many people named Smith is
because when wars were breaking out the
blacksmiths were spared the war they
wouldn't go fight and if they were
captured they'd be spared because they
can make weapons the people who made the
weapons were extremely valuable and the
and the Kings and the rulers would keep
them comfortable so they could keep
producing powerful tools for them then
you look look at these big tech
companies completely overpaid with money
who knows where it comes from they
barely work why they're making the
modern weapons well I we should take a
quick step back and say well why why
would they do this right the weapons why
are we making social media weapons turns
out this thing Charlie was talking about
a minute ago my favorite paper
criticizing what's called social
emotional learning which is this whole
brainwashing program the left is
replacing education with that's a can of
worms we don't have to get into right
now but there's this paper that
criticizes it from the left it's my
favorite paper that criticizes SEL is a
paper written from an old school
critical Marxist and so what he writes
is that the purpose of this kind of
narrative control he calls the paper
psycho data and what you are most
valuable what's most valuable about you
to this regime is your data why because
they can control you with it we don't
need a dollar backed by gold or oil we
could have a dollar backed by you giving
them something that's very valuable to
them which is the data used to control
you so he says that they're we're
talking about the algorithms not just TV
right the algorithms on your social
media they can feed you they can nudge
you with what they call nudge Theory how
you're supposed to think how you're
supposed to feel the goal of this entire
operation with social media is is to
create the environment in which they can
do this psychological pushing nudging of
you into different kinds of decision
trees that you might not have taken
otherwise so they can control you and
this guy Ben Williamson he's a leftist
writes his paper saying the social
emotional learning program in schools
this is what this is for it's to gather
massive amounts of data it's to use this
data to control people to make them
perfectly predictable economic consumers
perfectly controllable uh political
subjects and to control everybody
basically completely all the time at the
level of what he calls a psychocracy a
government through their psychology so
they think they're thinking for
themselves but they're thinking what the
algorithm taught them to think and you
therefore don't even have freedom of
thought this is his fear of what this is
this is what this is for this is the
kind of weapon that they want to build
this is a left-wing critique like
Charlie was predicting would be coming
down the pike and what he says is that
this is horrible and it's awful and we
have to watch out this is a leftist
saying this and then what does he point
to he said where does this come from
who's funding and he's like well we need
to go through it's very easy the world
economic forum is funding the United
Nations behind it the World Bank is at
the dead center of all of it you can all
of the players we're always talking
about are the people that are behind
this huge push whether it's through
social emotional learning in the schools
whether it's through the algerocracy of
government by algorithm through the
social media and this is again we come
back to Elon all of a sudden he's gonna
he's just this dude he's a rocket guy
he's gonna go rocket man is going to
kicks Elon or kicks Elton John off of
Twitter or whatever uh rocket man comes
in and uh he's going to go build new
algorithms that are fun and he has jokes
and he wants memes and he's going to
build these algorithms that are not
under their control and they freak out
but we had a I think it was philibonti
was on the show and he made a good point
he said with neuralink there is going to
be a chip in your brain that gives you
the tiniest dopamine hit that you don't
even realize when you when you're nudged
just in the right direction so you're a
regular person living a normal life
they're not going to come out and say
get rid of all your stuff oh nothing
you're just gonna sell something for
cash and it's gonna feel good and before
you realize it they're they're pushing
everybody with this control with this
chip Maybe it's a little far-fetched to
say just right now but that's the fear
of how is that any different than
scrolling through Instagram though yeah
exactly exactly you get your hearts on
your thing right you got a heart oh my
God 300 likes and all dopaminergic
manipulation that's right and Van life
remember that big trend on YouTube Van
life where they're promoting all these
these young couples who are that poor
girl died doing that Gabby something
yeah there was a uh article that we read
about a woman who said I retired at 36
and then when you read it you realize
one she didn't actually retire she's
still working and two she lives in a van
or she's traveling on a nomadic
lifestyle yeah when people think of
retiring they think of they had a family
they have a house they have a front yard
or something at least to that effect
it's about social engineering so people
accept their slavery because throughout
human history there there always was
some kind of despot or psychopath trying
to take over the world and I think the
really Smart Ones realized hey it takes
a lot of time and effort to to kill a
lot of people and I think in our modern
society what better way to take over
Society than course have people enslave
themselves and I think that's exactly
what's happening right now and I think
bullets have been replaced with tweets
bombs have been replaced with videos and
right now we are being engineered in
fifth generational Warfare in order to
destroy the free human spirit and that's
the bigger fight that's happening right
now that people need to realize more
than ever and this is why I always say
violence doesn't work because it's
something they know how to control it's
something they know how to manipulate
they know that it instills fear and is a
weapon for them that doesn't mean it's
easy to combat it just means you need to
understand the weapons they're using and
psychological manipulation yeah you make
better technology basically social media
is not a weapon on its face it's a
powerful force that can be weaponized
and it has been unfortunately by it
looks like alphabet meta Twitter these
things but Minds for instance we would
sit around and have ethics conversations
with how addictive should we make this
technology it's 88 too much for me I
can't I don't want people constantly on
it I want them to use it for the
function that it's deserved and
uh you could have made it 100 I could
you could you can make it like an
addictive you make it 101 something that
someone's never even seen they didn't
it's more powerful than what you thought
could be the most addictive substance on
Earth it's not ethical we don't take
information at mines we don't want your
data because it can be it can be scraped
the key I think is open source code so
you know what the code is telling people
and uh you want access to your data and
you want to limit you want to opt in
when you want to opt in you don't want
them to harvest your metrics you're
basically saying power to the people and
I think people should own their their
own data and make money off of it let me
contribute some optimism though because
the neural link thing is real the
manipulation of people and and people
are looking for for Hope and one people
just screamed refereeing by the way I
said grumpy the next hour that's Ian's
thing Ian's thing is graphene sorry I
wanna talk about graphene thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time